Let's talk about manias.
Let's start with Beatle mania.
Hysterical teenagers, crying, screaming, pandemonium.
Sports mania.
Deafening crowds,...
...all for one idea:...
...get the ball in the net.
Okay, religious mania.
There's rapture.
There's weeping.
There're visions.
Manias can be good.
Manias can be alarming.
Or manias can be deadly.
The world has a new mania:...
...a mania for learning English.
Listen as Chinese students practice their English by screaming it.
Change my life!
I want to change my life.
I don't want to let my parents down.
I don't ever want to let my country down.
Most importantly...
I don't want to let myself down.
How many people are trying to learn English worldwide?
2 billion of them.
A t-shirt.
A dress.
In Latin America, in India, in Southeast Asia, and most of all in China.
If you are a Chinese student, you start learning English in the third grade by law.
That's why this year, China will become the world's largest English - speaking country.